hi i'm william and today i'm going to
talk about what i call the quantum
supremacy details in inequality
so arguably the single most important
and famous inequality and all of quantum
information
is the so-called bell inequality and the
reason why the bell inequality is so
important
is that it makes an experimental
prediction about classical mechanics
that can be refuted by quantum mechanics
in particular what the bell inequality
says is that there is this game you can
play
called the chsh game which involves a
referee and uh two non-communicating
players
alice and bob such that the probability
they win this game using any strategy
that can be explained
by classical mechanics essentially
the probability they win in that case is
at most three-quarters or 75
uh and hence if you can show an
experiment in which
two players play this game without
communicating and they win with
probability greater than 75 percent
then somehow you have inherently you've
revealed something inherent about the
non-classical nature of the world
and indeed we know actually that
assuming the two players share
entanglement
uh let's say even just a single epr pair
then they actually can do
slightly better than 75 in fact they can
win with probability
cosine squared of pi over eight it turns
out which is about
85 so just slightly better
but this also raises the very natural
question of well
um suppose they had like unbounded
quantum resources
then what's the best that they could do
quantumly
uh and it turns out well so this brings
us to arguably the
second most important inequality in all
of quantum information
which is that sarah's an inequality and
the terrestrial inequality says that
actually
um assuming quantum mechanics this
cosine squared pi over eight is also
optimal which is kind of remarkable if
you think about it right
yeah you could imagine getting all the
way up to one
by you know some arbitrary correlations
or something
but even in this case it turns out
quantum mechanics is somehow limited
and besides just being a very natural
question to study
right um we also now know in hindsight
that
the um studying the stereocenter quality
was sort of the basis for the modern
study of non-local correlations and
non-local games
which very recently has culminated in
some fantastic results including
mip star equals re and the refutation of
the condom betting problem in
operative algebras so this is
certainly an important question to study
what i'm going to argue next is that
something very similar is happening
in the world of quantum supremacy so
um recently as in just a little bit over
a year ago
a team based at google announced the
first experimental demonstration of
quantum computational supremacy
and they did it for a task called random
circuit sampling
and the way this works is google would
choose a
random quantum circuit c so it's an n
qubit circuit
of fandom one and two cubic gates which
i've stylized in this figure
and the task they attempt to solve is
what they call
the lydia cross entropy heavy output
generation task
where your goal is to output a string z
on n bits such that this quantity is as
large as possible
uh and if you're wondering what this
quantity is this is just um
the probability of measuring z under
like the
the true output distribution of c so if
you were to simulate c
on like a a noiseless quantum device
this is the probability with which you
would see z
um now also just a little bit over a
year ago
aronson and gunn proved a uh
computational analog of the bell
inequality for this x-hog task
uh where they showed that for any
under a plausible complexity theoretic
conjecture
um no polynomial time classical
algorithm
can do substantially better than random
guessing
for this uh xog task right um
you know note that if you just guess z
uniformly at random you'll achieve like
z uh you'll achieve an uh linear cross
entropy score of like one over two to
the n just because they are
two to the n total output strings um and
ericsson and gun show that
um this is this is probably optimal
this is probably the optimal guessing
strategy of
computationally bounded classical
algorithms
and hence when google announced a
quantum
computer that achieved roughly 1.002
over 2 to the n where n is like 53
cubits
this is basically enough for them to
claim the first real demonstration of
quantum supremacy
and just like on the previous slide it's
also extremely natural to ask
well what's the best that one could do
for this problem
um using say let's say we had like a
noiseless perfect quantum computer fault
tolerant
but we're constrained by polynomial time
what's the best you can do
and this is what i call you know the
quantum supremacy analog of the teresa
quality right
and you know just like on the previous
slide there is like a a better quantum
algorithm
namely if you actually just run the
circuit c and just
as long as the circuit c like looks
sufficiently random
um then it turns out that like on an
ideal quantum device you would achieve a
linear cross entry score
of roughly 2 over 2 to the n so better
than this 1 over 2 to the n
and also sort of comparable to on the
previous slide
there is like a trivial information
theoretic upper bound
so it turns out that again if the
circuit c is like sufficiently random
and if you manage to somehow always find
like the largest amplitude
of an output string z then
uh if you always output that then you
would achieve roughly order n over 2 to
the n
but you know again this is sort of not
really satisfying because what we're
interested in is
what's the best that a computationally
efficient quantum algorithm could do
for this linear cross entropy benchmark
and that is the problem we study in this
work
and in this work we study this problem
in basically the simplest
non-trivial model in which this question
is interesting
and that is to say we study it in the in
the query or black box model
uh meaning we treat the circuit c as a
black box
so the quantum algorithm only gets to
make queries to see
and we'll also treat c as like a perfect
random
n qubit unitary matrix and
our main result shows that for this task
if you want to do
substantially better on this linear
cross-country benchmark than the
the trivial quantum algorithm then you
actually need to make an
exponential number of queries to see uh
roughly like 2 to the n over 4 where n
has the number of qubits
we also have some other results in this
paper so
in some cases we can actually replace
this random oracle by other oracles
and we also show a upper bound
so we can show a lower bound of like two
to the n over four
for this task but we can also show that
you can also do slightly better than two
over to the n
using just um two to the n over three
quantum queries and this is based on an
algorithm that uses the the quantum
collision fighting algorithm
uh so there are a few reasons to care
about this
um arguably the most obvious one is that
well
you know it's a real world problem if
you care about algorithm lower bounds
you know you should certainly care about
lower bounds for the only quantum
algorithm that anyone has ever
implemented
right i mean indeed one could even argue
that this is
uh to this date the first and only
algorithm regardless result for a
quantum algorithm has actually been
implemented
um another reason though is that it
turns out this problem is
is sort of interesting in its own right
even in this very restricted setting of
quantum query complexity
this turns out to be because this
problem really differs a lot
from the normal problems we tend to
study in quantum query complexity
um most query complexity problems
involve boolean oracles so you you query
like an n bit string and you get a zero
or one answer
but here the oracle is sort of
inherently this random quantum unitary
which is very different
additionally most query complexity
problems we study are decision problems
and this is not
right the task is to output some n-bit
string
satisfying a certain average
case property and you know there's
really no way to reduce this to just
like a decision problem
and these two things combined actually
basically mean that
all of the existing tools all the
existing lower bound techniques for
quantum query complexity are not going
to work here
um so for example the the the adversary
method which is very popular because it
is known to
tightly characterize the quant of cray
complexity of decision problems
is basically useless here because it's
not a decision problem
the polynomial method in principle could
be used here
um but it would be probably a lot more
cumbersome than normal because again
you don't have these boolean variables
but you have these
you know completely har random entries
so
both of these kind of suggest that we
need some new ideas to be able to tackle
a problem like this
and that's what i'm going to talk about
next
so i'm just going to say a little bit
about what i thought were some of the
interesting ideas that that went into
this work
and i'll start with the one i thought
was sort of the the most likely to
perhaps be applicable elsewhere and this
is something involving
so-called state preparation oracles so
imagine i have some n-qubit
state psi and i want to give my quantum
algorithm access to psi
so how can i do that well the simplest
thing you could do is just give the
algorithm copies of psi
but really what you'd like to be able to
do is say you know the algorithm should
be able to make as many copies of psi as
it wants what i want to do is give you
a unitary that allows you to produce
copies of psi
and in the literature the most common
way we
tend to give algorithms access to such
unitary is by what i like to call this
canonical state preparation oracle
and the way this works is uh we fix
um we fix some canonical
orthogonal state which i'll denote by
bot
and we'll consider the unitary u that
acts as follows
so it swaps bot and psi so if you feed
in the state bot which
you know you can think of this as being
like the all zeros input or something
if you feed in the all zeros input you
get back a copy of psi
if you feed in psi you get back the l
zero's input and otherwise this unitary
just acts completely trivially
um the reason i call this the canonical
oracle is that
besides being like arguably the simplest
way to produce copies of psy
it also turns out that this such an
oracle essentially follows in like a
black box way
from pretty much any other oracle that
lets you any other unitary oracle that
lets you produce copies of the psi
um but okay but for the purposes of our
work it's actually
very natural to consider a what looks
like a priori
and completely different uh model of
state preparation
so consider uh i give you a unitary
where i promise you
that the first column of this unitary
contains psi
which is just another fancy way of
saying that on the all zeros input
this unitary produces a copy of psi
but everywhere else this unitary is
going to be essentially completely
random
even like car random uh so there's no
guarantees on what it's going to be
elsewhere um
and you know somehow this feels very
different right because this is
you know a unique canonical oracle
whereas this is like a
an ensemble of of oracles even
um so what can we say about their
relative power well it turns out
um one of the key lembos in this work
shows that actually in the query
complexity world these two resources
are essentially equivalent uh in the
sense that
either one can approximately simulate
the other
to like inverse exponential precision
in in the number of cubits of psi
using a constant number of queries to
the other
i guess i will so i suppose like the
left implication was already known
because
like i said this is sort of the
canonical oracle but the right
implication is
is what's new uh and i can imagine
you know this this could be used uh
elsewhere where state preparation
oracles show up so in certain like
cryptographic protocols for example
this might be useful
but for our purposes is very useful
because it allows us to replace this
random oracle by this conceptually much
simpler object this canonical oracle
and indeed for this canonical oracle we
actually have some nice tools
for um proving lower bounds
in particular there's this theorem by
ambience rosmanius and unruh
in 2014 which shows that if i have a
quantum algorithm
that makes queries to this canonical
state preparation oracle
i can actually simulate this algorithm
approximately
by a different algorithm that makes no
queries at all
and instead starts with a resource state
and what this resource state consists of
is a bunch of copies of psi in
superposition with something else
and the number of copies we need is like
roughly the square
of the number of queries the algorithm
makes
and this is very nice and actually for
our problem
it even allows us to simplify it even
further so
whereas uh in this original theorem you
need copies of psi in superposition with
something else
actually it turns out for this problem
because of the symmetries of the problem
involving these output amplitudes of
this
linear cross entropy score you can
actually just
reduce it to algorithms that just start
with a bunch of copies of psi
so you make t queries you can just
consider algorithms that instead start
with like t squared copies of psi
and there it's actually relatively easy
to get a lower bound using again the
symmetries of the problem
i guess the intuition here turns out to
be that if you only have copies of psi
and you want to measure a string z such
that the amplitude on z
is large
basically your best strategy is to just
measure a bunch of copies of psi and
output whichever thing is
appears most often and intuitively
speaking
um you're not going to get you're not
going to do much better with a bunch of
copies of psy than with one copy of psy
unless you are able to start seeing
collisions so you measure the same
string z multiple times
but then this sort of turns into like a
birthday paradox problem
um if there's like two in the end
possible outputs
uh you need like two to the n over two
measurements to start seeing collisions
um and that's actually basically where
this uh this lower bound comes from
right so
uh you need at least like two to the n
over two copies of psi
and with two to the n over two copies of
psi you could simulate like two to the n
over four
queries to this state preparation oracle
so that's like the very high level
overview of of the important ideas
that went into this and and
how they contribute to the final lower
bound
so i'm just going to conclude with some
of my favorite open problems relating to
this um
perhaps the most obvious one left open
is to tighten the balance
right so right now there's a gap between
our lower bound and our upper bound
um i actually conjecture that this two
to the under three is
probably tight and that this um two at
the end of four can be improved
and i even have some ideas for how you
might be able to prove this which i
discuss in the paper um but for the time
being you know it's
i have no idea
another obvious question i guess is to
give
some stronger evidence that this problem
is actually hard in the real world
so for instance for the the classical
analog of this problem what i called the
uh the classical computational bell
inequality approved by erinsson and gunn
they gave a reduction to a problem which
involves estimating the output
probabilities of random quantum circuits
um and but
it it sort of looks like such a
reduction is just not going to work here
because the assumption they start with
is simply false for quantum computers
so it seems like probably some new ideas
would be needed to
to give um other evidence of hardness in
the real world where you don't just have
query access the circuit but where you
actually have an explicit description of
it
um but even like simpler problems i feel
like are
um we don't really know how to answer
and actually one thing i think
might be interesting to explore is um
to what extent do these random quantum
circuits exhibit
computational pseudorandomness
properties right
so sort of implicit in in this work is
some assumption that
if you replace this distribution of
random polynomial
size quantum circuits by the har measure
then um computationally your algorithm
is still going to do basically about the
same
on this linear cross entropy score and
somehow this is a sort of like
pseudorandomness assumption even in this
restricted query complexity model and
i think it would be nice to better
understand like to what extent this
assumption is well founded
so we know that like in certain regimes
uh
random quantum circuits sort of
information theoretically approximate
the r measure
but i actually conjecture that there
should be a stronger pseudo-randomness
property
um that holds against even like
exponentially powerful quantum
algorithms
uh and it would be nice to give some
evidence for this or just to better
understand these sorts of questions
um so that about concludes the talk so
that's everything i wanted to say
um if you have any questions you are
more than welcome to email me but
otherwise
i will see you at the live version of
this talk
in itcs
you